This question,
what does a patient is basic and
important and deserves the short summary?
So let's just recap what is the patient?
Patients are mosaics of parts
that have very different ages.
On the left you see the
illustration showing when the
transposon inserted into the protal
immunoglobulin gene to make possible the
vertebrate adaptive immune system that
happened about 500 million years ago.
Some of the very oldest parts like
intermediate metabolism are precise and
efficient because they have been
shaped by billions of selective events.
They are also very hard to change.
Some of the most recent responses have
not had had time to adapt to change
conditions and so they are
maladaptive mismatches.
Secondly,
patients of different ethnicities have
genes that have experienced different
histories of exposure to disease and diet
and the illustration evokes a g was a
genome wide association studies showing
that in a particular part of Africa
there is a particular region of the
chromosome that provides resistance to
tuberculosis.
Yeah,
because patients vary in their ability
to resist disease and metabolize drugs.
Individualized medicine can probably
produce more accurate treatment,
but it doesn't come cheap.
Another feature of patients is that they
have a particular life history and the
human life history is an unusual,
humans have only recently evolved
altricial young childhood,
Short Inter birth intervals and menopause.
They are not yet as precisely
and elegantly designed
is ancient traits because
they have been shaped by
many fewer selective events
and you can see that girls
and boys have also evolved very
different growth trajectories with girls
maturing earlier than boys.
Okay.
The next important aspect of patients
is that their products of their
developmental histories as well
as their evolutionary histories,
they react to diet, exercise, and
disease with plastic responses.
Here are the evil brothers
who are identical twins.
This one undertook long distance running
at 18 and at the same age his brother
took up weightlifting.
Okay.
This makes the point that patients are
points on reaction norms and reaction
surfaces that integrate their
individual developmental histories.
Okay.
It also emphasizes that events
occurring very early in life in Utero,
perinatal and postnatally have
large impacts on the rest of life.
Patients are also bundles of
tradeoffs and because of that,
most interventions have side effects
because changes in one trade or linked to
changes and other traits genetically
develop mentally and physiologically,
and we evoke that idea with the y model
of tradeoffs where a certain resource
coming into the organism is being
split here between two functions,
between fecundity and survival.
This means that it's almost impossible
to change any one thing without changing
something else that might be significant
or not significant depending on the
circumstances,
but all traits in an organism
are tied together to some degree.
Some side effects are important
and we need to be aware of them.
Patients also are organisms that age
and they were not selected to age and to
die the age because they were selected
for reproductive performance and
reproduction has costs in repair,
maintenance,
defense and mortality that were worth
paying an evolutionary currency.
Many patients and doctors of course,
do not see it that way.
Okay.
Another very interesting developing part
of our vision of what is a patient is
that early experience makes quite a
difference and we evoked that with this
picture from the Dutch hunger.
Winter nutrition in Utero in infancy
affects the risk of cardiovascular disease
type two diabetes and obesity decades
later as well as some other diseases.
And if we also look into the Microbiota,
we can see that we need to be very careful
about disrupting the microbiota and
that's because of our recognition
that there is continual,
there's initial crosstalk and then there
is continuing crosstalk between the
immune system and the Microbiota both in
the gut and in the skin epithelium and
in the lung epithelium and elsewhere.
The microbiota are effected by C-sections,
by breastfeeding and antibiotic therapy
and that has consequences for asthma,
atopy,
autoimmune diseases and obesity.
I should also point out that if we have
large antibiotic treatments that pretty
much wipe out the intestinal Microbiota,
it opens up the possibility of a c
difficile infection which can kill people.
So here again,
events that are happening very early in
life when the gut is initially colonized,
have disproportionate
impact on the rest of life.